this is the moment opposition supporters
say police fired tear gas as they
gathered at the home of opposition udp
leader usain idabo
the tenth standoff happened at dabo's
home just across the street from the
united states embassy in the sarakunda
area
supporters claim their candidate was
robbed in saturday's presidential
election and they won't back down
incumbent adamabarro has again been
declared president
his first time came after the oppressive
22-year rule of former leader yaya
jammeh
we want barrow to step down they rigged
the election the results are worse than
what was announced during yaya james
reign even he didn't defeat the udp with
this margin
witnesses say the skirmish began after a
stone was cast at the police who then
responded with tear gas
and arrests
incidents like this have been reported
elsewhere
witnesses say clashes have happened
between supporters of the governing
party and the main opposition
we are not happy with the results
but not being happy with the result does
it mean that we have to adapt measures
that run contrary to the law
we the laws of the gambia have provided
us
the remedies that we could have
ourselves
and those remedies you must pursue
hopes of gambia's post-election period
will be hit free or dashed by these
incidents now even the position of
opposition leader hussein udabo
regarding the outcome of this election
suffered a setback on monday one of the
candidates who attended a meeting in his
house while the results of the elections
were rejected
called and congratulated president adama
barrow
election observers from both the african
union and european union found no major
problems in the electoral process
other candidates like halifa salla have
already considered defeat saying
gambians have spoken why they voted the
way they voted is not my prerogative to
inquire into they have water is their
voice if made their voices heard
it is for us to accept
their decision
the police have issued a statement
vowing to deal with troublemakers and
with some opposition supporters saying
they won't back down it could be a tense
post-election period for the gambia
ahmed idris al jazeera banjol the gambia